let's talk about Russia the more we
learn about Russian involvement in the
2016 presidential election it's becoming
clearer and clearer that the United
States and Donald Trump have fallen
victims I don't think is too far to go
to a sort of new Cold War tactic that is
going on US intelligence agencies now
say that they have quote high confidence
that Russia acted late in the 2016
presidential election specifically to
hurt Hillary Clinton and to help Donald
Trump become the president-elect
Russians hacked the Republican National
Committee's computer systems in addition
to the Democratic organizations they
didn't release what they got from RNC
computers and the CIA has now concluded
in what was a secret assessment that yes
Russia intervened in this election to
help Donald Trump win the presidency
originally there was this idea Pat that
okay Russia packing what they're trying
to do is just undermine confidence in
the electoral system of the United
States it now appears and by the way
James Comey was briefed on this in
September and chose to say nothing about
it during that press conference about
Hillary Clinton's emails it now appears
that it wasn't just Russian involvement
to undermine the American electoral
system it was Russian involvement to
help a particular candidate become the
next president of the United States of
course Trump says we shouldn't trust any
of it
citing faulty Iraq war intelligence
saying I don't believe they interfered
basically saying you can't trust the CIA
and other American intelligence agencies
that he will be soon leading as
president of the United States this is a
very different story and this has
massive implications yeah and the reason
why Russia would want to install Trump
as the president are pretty clear
because he said that he would look into
labeling Crimea as part of Russia
yeah he's voiced the staying for NATO
and a whole host of other things
attacking the media among them not to
mention his presumed choice for
Secretary of State which we will get to
a little bit later a foreign power one
that in 2012 Mitt Romney called our
greatest geopolitical
Nicoll foe has acted to affect the
results of an internal election in the
United States this cannot become
partisan Russia interfering in American
elections should not be a Republican
versus democratic issue but it already
is number one according to several
official Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell made it clear to the
administration the Obama administration
that he would consider any effort by the
White House to challenge the Russians
publicly an act of partisan politics no
wait wait wait wait wait wait
saying we are going to investigate how
and whether a foreign power might have
manipulated our election is now being
called partisan by Republican Mitch
McConnell who by the way has a wife that
is going to be part of the Donald Trump
administration let me remind you that
according to these revelations
congressional leaders were briefed in
September Mitch McConnell made sure that
nobody would hear about the reality that
we knew Russia was acting to help Donald
Trump until after election day now we
know Russia was involved and by the way
FBI director James Comey also knew of
Russian aid to the Trump campaign in
September and somehow Pat James Comey
forgot or neglected to mention that
Russia was helping Trump when giving
that ridiculous press conference about
Hillary Clinton and her emails this is a
new Cold War tactic and it is shameful
yeah there are plenty of things that
could have shifted the election the
other way and I think this is out at the
forefront of look what could have
changed it I remember being on the
treadmill at my gym and I was watching
CNN and congressman Michael McCall
inadvertently said hey you know what
Russia also hacked the RNC and Wolf
Blitzer said are you saying congressman
that Russia also hacked the RNC is that
we were saying why hasn't that been
announced and McCall saying that you
know I don't know why I don't know and I
found it incredible because he was the
only person saying this within hours of
that interview the RNC and McCall said
oh whoa whoa whoa now I misspoke
actually we don't have any evidence of
that
we now know that they did have evidence
of that and it was deliberately covered
up
there's a growing rift between Donald
Trump and many in the Republican Party
over this a quote from Michael Hayden
NSA director and CIA director in there
George W Bush to have the
president-elect of the United States
simply reject the fact-based narrative
that puts that the intelligence
community puts together because it
conflicts with his a priori assumptions
Wow
Congressman Peter King Republican of New
York saying there's little doubt that
the Russian government was involved in
these hacks one of trumps most
enthusiastic supporter supporters
congressman Devin Nunez saying that
there is no doubt whatsoever about
Russia's culpability here and of course
senators John McCain and Lindsey Graham
I guess we could call them the
occasional voices of reason of the
Republican Party also saying that every
American should be alarmed by this and
it needs to be looked into this is all
part of the most glaringly illegitimate
election we've had in the United States
up for a very very long time
the sketchiest of circumstances with
Russian involvement Trump voters many
having been bamboozled into thinking
that this is all going to be great for
them how on earth are people not more
bothered by Russian interference and by
the way Trump and his cronies like
Kellyanne Conway saying we really just
can't believe what our own intelligence
agencies tell us here's Kellyanne Conway
being interviewed about this over the
weekend and then when he was asked about
this question which is coming from the
intelligence community he said that that
he it was not a talk he said it was a
laughing point in other words the notion
that the Russians were involved in the
action was laughable and so I'm just
wondering how he can both respect the
intelligence community and then think
something they're telling him is
laughable that seems to be a disconnect
yeah it's completely compatible Oh he
absolutely respects the intelligence
community he's made very clear he's
going to put his own people in there as
well what he has said is laughable and
ridiculous is this entire notion which
people are just using as a foregone
conclusion that somehow this was meant
to defeat Hillary Clinton and elevate
him to the presidency just unbelievable
think about the undertone Trump and his
surrogates are crafting the narrative
that we simply cannot trust big picture
the
CIA and other intelligence agencies now
he'll talk about Iraq and it's true that
we were completely misled on Iraq but it
was the Bush administration itself that
was the catalyst for using this
information into making : powell make
the case with information we need to be
sketchy don't be tricked by donald trump
and his associates about that getting
gifts that people like during the
holiday season is important but doing it
without having to go to a mall or stand
in a line or deal with crowds makes it
even better and to be perfectly honest
that's a pretty high priority for me
which is why it's a really great idea so
instead of going to the mall you go to
the Omaha Steaks website they offer
unique gifts for gourmet food lovers
it's not just steaks it's also seafood
and poultry and veggies and desserts and
appetizers the entire thing there's
actually over 500 gourmet gift ideas at
Omaha Steaks calm and so importantly
it's convenient and fast shopping for
whoever is on your list this year online
recipes wine pairings much much more and
right now Omaha Steaks is giving
exclusive savings to david pakman show
listeners and viewers listen to
everything you get for under fifty bucks
to filet mignons to top sirloins for
boneless chicken breasts for burgers a
twelve ounce package of all beef
meatballs potatoes gratin
for caramel apple tartlets and much much
more it's a very long list all for under
fifty bucks you can go to Omaha Steaks
com but then here's the key thing you
put in my code Pakman PA que ma n in the
search bar add the family gift pack to
your cart and you'll get a seventy seven
percent savings and you avoid the lines
at the mall Omaha Steaks comm code is
Pakman in the search bar